[Music]
as we head into the dog days of summer i
want to get you guys up to speed on some
behind the scenes happenings as well as
tell you a bit about my plans for the
near future
before i do that i quickly want to
address my conversation with patreon ceo
jack conte
from earlier this week i think that this
chat as much as
anything that we've done here gets to
the heart of what i've tried to do with
the reuben report for the past two years
jack and i had an honest conversation
about new media and personal liberty
couched around the issue that i care
most about free speech
i hope that whether you came away from
the interview agreeing with jack or not
that you got a better understanding of
the complexities and contradictions
that we all face whether you're a
creator a ceo
or a supporter of online content as i
mentioned time and time again i believe
it's
vital to occasionally put down your
phone disconnect from the grid
and reconnect with the real world this
is something i've tried to incorporate
into my life as much as possible but
usually it's much harder than it should
be
the constant need to be online and in
the discussion whatever that discussion
is
can be incredibly inspiring and valuable
but it can also be
incredibly draining and time sucking
beyond just doing the reuben report i've
been trying to work on a book for the
past
year as well as catch up on some side
projects while also
setting a little time for some mental
clarity with this in mind i want to lay
out
the rest of my summer for you this week
on the show we have british columnist
and commentator katie hopkins who's sure
to trigger many of those who are
triggerable
and then i head to new york city to do
the greg gutfeld show on saturday
after that i'll be truly experiencing
one of the highlights of my professional
career as i interview richard dawkins at
the 92nd street y in new york city
the event sold out almost immediately
before i even had a chance to mention it
to you guys but the fine folks at the y
are giving us the video of the whole two
hour interview which will be shot in
front of about 2 000 people
and we'll be posting it right here on
our channel next week
after this interview with dawkins i'll
be going off the grid completely
completely for the rest of the summer
until september 5th
the day after labor day fear not though
you will be getting new reuben report
episodes every week
we've already taped interviews with
professor gad sad column this guy
benson economist pia milani and chairman
of the iran institute your own brook
since we've taped these interviews
already i can promise you that you're
going to dig
all of them and each episode is truly
different from one another
what we may lose in filming and
releasing in the same week i promise you
that you'll get back with a continued
focus on ideas
rather than news cycles while we will
post all these videos as scheduled i
will not be on social media of any kind
until september 5th
that's right i am not going to tweet i
am not going to post on facebook
share anything on instagram or anywhere
else we're going to automate a couple
posts in advance so that we can promote
our weekly episodes but i won't be
sharing anything else checking mentions
or even reading the news i look forward
to having some relaxation time on the
beach but
for the most part i'll be spending most
of my time during this break catching up
on reading exercising
and most importantly focusing on this
book which is long overdue
basically i'm not going to look at
screens of any kind except for when i'm
writing this book i'm sure people
try to talk to me about the news but i'm
going to do everything in my power to
truly shut down and really escape from
the day-to-day play-by-play madness yes
i will miss some trump tweets i'll miss
some outrages and i'll miss whatever
else happens in the world
but i do have a suspicion that the world
will keep spinning without me
and at the same time i also have a
suspicion that i'll be better off for
this
break afterwards it seems kind of crazy
to take a vacation and truly escape the
web these days but that was pretty much
the norm only a decade ago
if the world does end while i'm gone i
suppose it'll have to end without me
live tweeting it
more importantly than anything else
though i just want to thank all of you
who not only watch this show but share
it with friends and family
and who are having these conversations
in your own lives
there is absolutely no doubt that the
issues that we're talking about here
are taking root in the real world and
that real change is on the horizon
if i didn't think that we could change
the world by having these honest
conversations on the importance of free
speech
and individual liberty i assure you that
i would do something else
after all it's never too late for me to
pick up my mba dreams
before i sign off though i want to give
a special shout out to all of you who
have supported us on patreon
and paypal since we went independent
about 14 months ago
you guys have truly truly helped me make
my dreams come true
and now you're giving me and my crew a
little breathing room allowing me to
work on this book
and helping us all take it to the next
level i already have a packed schedule
of speaking gigs and college events
coming up this fall and i look forward
to coming back more focused and
invigorated than ever before
without your support not only couldn't
we do this show at the professional
level
with which we do it but there's
certainly no way i could take a few
weeks to clear the mind and plot the
future
maybe some of you will join me on this
technology-free couple weeks but for
those of you who don't i know you'll
enjoy everything we've cooked up for you
while we're gone
again thank you all for your support and
generosity
and as we enter season three of the
reuben report in september
i promise you this is just the beginning
[Music]
joining me today is a british media
personality a columnist an
author and a businesswoman who
apparently triggers everyone
katie hopkins finally welcome finally
i'm here
thank you very much for having me yeah
it's my pleasure we were going to do
this about a year ago and then
something happened traveled i know i got
sent
somewhere to cover something else or god
knows what happened but i was supposed
to be here but finally
i'm sitting in your studio and i'm
thrilled to be here and i love your
studio it's very posh
thanks oh posh that's you are british i
am i'm as british as they come
yes all right we have a lot to talk
about uh you're here
uh i assume mostly to do the reuben
report that's why you're in l.a but also
you do that's all i live for you
all i've lived for for like a month and
a half literally i like wake up and go
reuben
yeah yeah uh you did politicon you've
been around all of these political
pundits and the screaming people and the
partisan nut bags and all of that stuff
yeah i can tell just in the little brief
moments that we've spent together you
love this stuff
truly love it i love it and the thing i
love most i speak to the organizer last
night for politicon who's a regular guy
actually a brit as well as it turns out
the thing i love best about politicon is
not even the people
on the stage or the panelists or the
people that might think they're
important
the people that made politicon for me
were the people cueing this enormous
line
of people just queuing round and round
and round to queue up for whatever it
was they were passionate about
over the road behind the fencing there
was a little group of people who were
trump
supporters with their van with a little
trump mask just there to kind of go
liberals we're here we're even opposite
the road to scare you
and i love that i love that people
particularly americans are super engaged
with
politics at the moment they're super
engaged with the process they're willing
to commit
funds to it and i think that's what
trump has also
blessed america with is reinvigorating
this enthusiasm
for getting involved i think that's a
great thing yeah so one of the things
that i've been saying about trump and i
i did not vote for trump i didn't
support trump but i had trump
we can talk about you we can talk all
about it i came here with goodwill for
you yeah
listen that's why we're here didn't even
vote for trump oh man i was going to
tell you halfway through but all right
but what i think that is better than
anything else
is that trump has as some of my guests
have said he's drove a truck through
the store and my my metaphor is that
he's taken the chessboard and thrown it
up that everything is such a mess right
now
that there is a new enthusiasm there is
fertile ground in all of that
and i think that's far more valuable in
many ways than this policy or that
policy or anything else
yes so true and in a way your version of
a mess
might be that somebody just got fired
after only 11 days in a job or maybe
your version of a mess
is that someone else had to leave and
someone leaked and someone was nasty and
someone said rude words but for me
coming from the uk and london you know a
mess for us
is a country that is not going to
enforce brexit that
we voted for 52 of us voted for we may
not ever see that and mess for me is
uh in 24 hours since i left the uk uh
there were four
stabbings two acid attacks and a riot
and then of course we've come off the
back of a summer where we've been uh run
down by trucks blown up on bridges and
stabbed with hunting knives when we're
out
trying to have a meal with our family so
your version of a mess
in terms of a political system and
organized chaos is is quite different to
my reference of
a mess understand is a mess yeah so you
would really argue that
the mess you're dealing with even though
for the people that are triggered or
upset by trump
that your mess is much worse yeah and
many ways you know i
look to america as kind of hope like
inspiration
hope you've got someone tough in the
white house that's determined to get
things done
you've got a whole group of people who
believe they've been forgotten which to
me is the brexiteers it's the same it's
the rest of uk
that's the rest of america that isn't
california or isn't new york
uh the rest of america got their voice
heard and that really speaks to the
brexiteer in me
where the rest of the uk finally got to
say to london
no you think you're smart you think
you're liberal you don't live amongst
the migration you don't live with what
we live with
and you're going to listen to us and i
think trump did that and i love that he
does it
yeah tell me a little bit about your
where your politics came from like
growing up and
were you always into politics what
happened here
what happened to me i didn't know my
father asked that on a fairly regular
basis
actually he told me to ask that yeah
what happened i bet
my father says if i marry anyone else
i'm out of the will so like he has some
rules for me and those are his basic
rules now there's no more weddings ever
for me i'm already on husband too
but i call him like my current husband
just to keep him like
a little bit anxious a little bit
anxious um what happened to me i don't
know so i was just a regular kid
i went to a convent school can blame the
nun somewhere in there
yeah and then i kind of like debating
and then i went into
so i was army industry was in manhattan
for 10 years in the east village i lived
love
and um and then from there i went on to
the
british version of the apprentice and it
seems that from there i kind of segued
into media i had no plan to do that
i had no desire to be media and
commentary
but after the apprentice kind of media
just sort of took me up
and took me over and then there became
this kind of little space
uh for someone who was prepared to say
it really straight who didn't
necessarily want to be liked who doesn't
have an
agent or a publicist or a legion of prs
trying to pretend that i'm something
that i'm totally not i am just this
and uh and i think that's where i sort
of found my niche
and i think that the more i live amongst
london and the more i work amongst
a liberal establishment the elite the
left wing
the more actually my platform grows
because people see that the list of
things we can't say
is longer than the list of things we can
and when they're silenced they kind of
look to me and say well at least she's
still speaking
and that's what really annoys the
lefties is the more they try and
shut things down silence me the bigger
my voice and it really annoys them and i
say to them you know
you are frankenstein and i am your
monster
that really annoys them and i love that
well it's like
milo when i had milo on before he was
milo when people were just kind of
finding out i had my hair done in his
honor
he told me he had his hair done people
are like is that milo i'm like no it is
not it is his sister
well i think you have more than hair
just in common because he kept saying to
me right at the beginning when i had him
on really before he had gotten anywhere
close to the milo that we
we now know he said well look if these
guys want to beat me i'll tell you how
to beat me don't show up stop
protesting me blah blah blah you know he
wanted attention
and yet they kept doing the wrong thing
do you find consistently that your
intellectual opponents or
the people that don't like you that they
just they won't even do the work to sort
of beat your ideas that it's just about
silencing
it's yes exactly right so they've become
smarter you know i watch them they're
like
amoeba or like some kind of virus or
disease
and i watch them evolve so they sort of
worked out that antibiotic
and how to beat that and now they've
evolved to get the next one so their
latest iteration of themselves
is to go at your commercial sponsors or
to go at your boss or to go your boss's
boss or
to try and take you down that way and
that's upsetting to me not because i
lose platforms because
i'll accept that that's no problem it's
that i would much rather they were sat
in that chair opposite me
and take me down because you're smarter
than me take me down because your
arguments are better than mine
take me down because okay you didn't
know trump was going to win i did
okay you didn't call brexit i did but
don't take me down because i happened to
be right and you were wrong
be better than me and i don't see that
yet but i do see the way that
groups of the establishment of the left
can influence commercial sponsors and of
course that will remove a platform any
day of the week
yeah it's funny that the first thing you
said we only talked for a couple minutes
before
we started but we were talking about how
i built this thing here
there's this craziness now with there's
some stuff with patreon that i did an
interview with earlier in the week
and there's all sorts of demonetization
things and all that
now you're working for a a mainstream
publication
but you still have those same pressures
of well then are they going to come for
your job or they
or what else are they going to
absolutely and you know of course so if
i'm a daily mail columnist
there is the reputation of mailonline
dailymail.com that sits
with me they can go after that they can
use communities of individuals you know
i'm so pro-israel
jews i want to be i'm an ambitious jew
myself i'm not one but i want to be one
like when i grow up i have this nose
yeah like i want to be jewish like
that's my life goal
i got born with a nose and yet still
didn't get to be jewish which is like
totally unfair and yet randomly these
lefties will sometimes
find a group of maybe rabbis that are a
part of their hope not hate you know we
have hope not hate yes
and then they use the rabbis i'm like
but i'm your biggest fan
so they will use people to try and
influence my bosses
the paper to try and suggest that their
association with me is in some way
harming their brand
whereas in reality of course all it
takes is for me to put up a column
that then is the most red column that
week and it's so infuriating because
therefore i'm useful to the paper yeah
so how much of your political ideology
which obviously i want to get into
how much of it is based either just
purely in like
politics and you know the things behind
philosophy versus just
life yeah just the piece that's just
like well screw these guys who got
everything wrong and they're still
preening and preaching and trying to
take my job and the rest of it yeah i
mind
i think my stuff definitely comes much
more from life so it hasn't been that
i've just like
i'm i'm kind of i don't know geek that i
kind of watch a lot of news or watch a
lot of politicians and then i have
something to say about that i don't feel
that way at all
what i feel it's much more it's much
more authentic to me it's much more
inside of me
the things i feel so the reason i wanted
uh to be in the forces you know i went
to sandhurst i was sponsored
by the intelligence corps through
university a great surprise to most
people who like to say that i'm stupid
as one of my labels
um is that i wanted to defend my country
i wanted to fight for my country i was
going to be the first female general
you know i'm a proud patriot so that's
in me
and then when i went into business you
know the idea that the free market is
the answer that small state limited
state
is the answer to be a true libertarian
you will not prescribe
how you can spend your money what your
health care comes from
uh how you will you know spend your time
i think we need limited state
that comes from my time in business and
then certainly
operating with people like things like
the apprentice or whatever just watching
human nature
watching how easy how quickly you can
work someone out
what they're like what they think how
they work how you can take them down
i love all of that and that kind of
builds into my debate stuff or the stuff
i do on tv where it's easy
to see a weakness and you can just take
people out on it yeah so is that part of
when when people criticize you and well
she says this she taught you know even
actually i got less this time which i
think is a good
sign that the first time i said i was
having you on but again about about a
year ago
i got all these people she's racist
she's a big and she's like she's stupid
yeah this time uh i think maybe i sent
the tweet out at an odd time at night
also so you never know and i don't know
awake at two in the morning you know
it's funny i know it would be virtually
impossible to offend you but i suppose
if i was to say
well i tweeted something out that i'm
having on unless people are upset that
actually might offend you because you'd
be like
maybe i'm not maybe i'm not doing my job
properly no i think things have changed
a little but i think that
shows that that reason in a way
is working because people are getting
less
outraged by hearing some some common
sense stuff i i look at your
twitter sometimes and oh yeah yeah well
go uh maybe she said that in a little
way that i wouldn't have said it or this
yeah it's just not
exactly how i operate of course but i
never from what i've seen i've never
seen blatant racism
or anti-semitic stuff or
islamophobia is not a word but i i
really haven't seen that no
that's not the truth so are you not a
bigoted racist
i don't mind you know i i say go for it
like if you like labels
go for it if you can add an ist onto
something and make me
it if that's your hobby go crazy like
you're probably at home you probably
still live with your mom you're probably
in her spare room
your keyboard is definitely sticky maybe
give it a wipe sometime if you're really
bored with your life like
you probably still like floss your teeth
with your own toenails and eat your own
ear wax i don't mind but you're going to
call me a racist a fattist
love that one an islamophobe whatever i
i believe i'm none of those things i can
show you and demonstrate to you
through argument through what i do
through the stories that i've told the
columns i've written i'm none of those
things
i understand that if you lack the
vocabulary and the intellect be able to
take me down with an
argument you think a label will suffice
what you will have seen over 10 years of
throwing those labels at me is that i
still haven't really shut up
yeah and i think the other thing people
see is they do see what you see
is that i get so much sort of thrown at
me so much aggression or people imagine
that i get assaulted in the street
i don't but that people say i'm going to
come and rape you with a machete
you know okay good but it won't fit
because it seems yeah
it's fine you know like i'm gonna come
and lock you in your car and set fire to
it oh sure you know
whatever makes you feel good you lack
the language to be able to articulate
the way that you're crossed with me
then i understand that people are cross
with me because i have a different view
to them
um i don't accept many of the things
that are seen as the
tick box of right answers that you have
to have in the uk
i don't accept that we should just have
open borders i don't accept that we
should
pander to muslim as a and islam as a
religion i don't accept
for example i was speaking yesterday
with a bunch of a room full
of feminists i mean you could just hear
them just kind of melting
when i spoke but you know my challenge
to them is where are you
where are you you feminazis when women
have got burkas on when they've got
three
you know they're allowed to take
husbands are allowed to take three wives
where
are you for the muslim rape squads in
the uk i don't hear you talking about
that where were you
when in cologne on new year's eve there
were 1 200 sexual assaults
i don't hear you same with black lives
matter
went to a debate yesterday the woman
stood up the first thing she said do we
all agree
that black lives matter and the room
went crazy
and it's like you have got to we are we
really at a point where someone was
saying black lives didn't matter
is that the best you've got who bumped
into the niece
of martin luther king in the foyer on my
way to come and see you
and asked her you know what's your view
on black lives matter and she said they
are just
paid protesters and they need to just
stop
yeah she hates this identity politics
totally and that's from the niece of
martin luther king and you go
she's probably got a point and i think
this identity politics
has to stop i watched the [ __ ] marches
in
uh washington when i went to the
inauguration of trump
best day of my life and uh i went to the
[ __ ] marches to see what they were
about and you know they were just so
pathetic so some women had banners with
save the environment some had banners
with black lives matter
some were vegetarians and wanted to tell
you about that and others were like
here because my [ __ ] is made of steel
like
make up your mind why why are you here
you don't know you're just a coalition
of weakness and victimhood
be better like women need to be better
than that and they're not and women have
never been more disappointing
i can it's obvious to me that not a lot
gets to you but to me if i were you
that would get to me as a woman that
that just by saying all these things the
mainstream
woman hood is not a sister yeah whatever
yeah okay so they're writing the witch
master cauldrons of witches
i don't know what the collective noun is
for witches but it's that
witches i think yeah um but that thing
that they would turn on you
i mean whether they like your politics
or not you're a strong independent woman
with a
track record and a resume and all of
those things so you'd think there would
be a little they might say yeah we don't
like the way she talks about this but
you think there would be a little room
in this wide umbrella
but the purpose their whole purpose is
to get rid of people
absolutely and i quite like the idea
they can't i like the idea that i'm a
woman so men
find it a bit tricky to directly
challenge me unless they're threatening
to you know kill me on twitter and women
find me really awkward because i
am one and yet i don't say the things
they need it to say
so you can see the women in the room
look at me going but she sort of is a
woman
but she's not supporting endless
maternity leave she's not supporting the
fact that we should have all female
shortlists she won't buy into the idea
that
we should definitely have equal pay at
all times she won't buy into the idea
that
equal treatment all you have to say is
say that and it means something
if you listen to what the women's march
and
and the women's groups say all their
words come out but i still
hear nothing they mean nothing you say
to them so what's come from the [ __ ]
marches the women's marches
what have you achieved tell me some
definitive outcomes
from the women's marches nothing nothing
there's just nothing
i so what will you advise women to do
rise up
rise up that's all you're here what rise
up where go where what are you rising up
for
what are you achieving they achieved
nothing because they have no clear aim
no strategy and no way of delivering it
and i think that's very disappointing
where do you think that's worse do you
think that's worse in britain or in the
united states that that intersectional
thing because
it we know it's pretty terrible here but
i suspect it's probably pretty close
i think it's probably pretty close i
think it's i think so
usually what happens in america comes to
us i think uh whatever you guys are up
to whether it's
taking masses of prescription drugs
eventually we'll catch up and do the
same
together yeah thank you and if you get
kind of chronically obese
eventually all of britain will follow
that we do sorry about that yeah yeah
yeah i'm not here to like don't
apologize
i would like to apologize for america
now um
but i do think uh things like the way
that we've divided ourselves by these
groups of victims
and the way you get ahead on the left is
by being a bigger victim than the other
victim or
less well represented or somehow made to
feel like you were a minority group
that is not unique to america i think we
suffer from it i think hillary clinton
was the kind of you know she was the
sort of flag
bearer for that she just waved the flag
if you're a victim
saw yourself as a victim of minority
then go to clinton you know and that's
why obviously she lost that's why she
had no cohesive policies that i ever
remember
and but that's definitely playing out in
the uk young people
the first thing they identify with isn't
their country
or necessarily a political party it's
what their weakness is
and how they can be more weak than the
next person so that they own the
victim's status and that
is tragic so outside of the the people
like you that are outspoken
talking about and kind of being fun
about it and everything else how do you
fix the system i mean how do you get the
education system to go
being a victim is not something that you
want to do later in life like
how do you actually do concrete steps to
fix some of this stuff
so i kind of commit to doing two or
three talks
a month inside of schools or colleges
that will allow me in and we would
appreciate that window is ever narrower
also my main following on twitter so i
have kind of 800 000
twitter followers whatever uh that my
main following is actually very young
people there's also the oldies that just
sort of see me as this kind of
they hold on to me in some nostalgic way
like i represent what britain used to be
like
but actually it's the young people that
follow and the young people that email
me to say
you know you i can't say what you say i
can't i can't even i'm not allowed to
think the things you think but i love
that you do it
i love that you do i'm holding on to you
because they're in schools and colleges
where they're being brainwashed just as
you are here with your campuses
and they can no longer say any of the
things that they would want to say
you know i have stories from kids that
were in politics class that said
i'm thinking of a caller to my radio
show her mother that her son
said that he supported trump and
eventually he was bullied out of that
politics class
even and told by the lecturer that he
should have
less radical thoughts you know i know
primary school that handed out clinton
mints
in the playground the night before in
britain you know the night
literally handed out mints with clinton
on so that the kids would know clinton
was the right answer
you know we have kids at age four and
five who had to raise their hands
if their parents voted for brexit and
they were made to feel silly and went
home and said
oh you know we were made to feel silly
in class because you were the ones that
voted brexit so
and after trump got in our school
children were sent home and told in
primary schools
you'll go home tonight and your parents
will be crying and your parents will be
very upset because the wrong
person won and in this school we don't
support hate
and they're allowed to teach that and
that is a very curious thing
because whilst we're trying to embrace
this kind of idea of multiculturalism
and
you know we're all equal and it's great
that we have muslims in our classes
that therefore means if trump comes up
with something labeled a muslim ban
trump equals hate and the school takes
that as permission to
teach an entire generation of young
people
trump equals hate and and that i find
that very hard that the left tried to
own the word
hope and they try to leave hate for
everybody else so that i become
a hate preacher it drives me crazy yeah
you gave me a lot there okay
so all right so let's talk about islam
because the i don't know if you know
this but a lot of people are talking
about it
you're talking about it a lot so how
much of this it's hard for me
sometimes when i follow certain people
on twitter to figure out how much of
this stuff
is actually real versus just sort of we
you know if everyone and i'm not saying
you specifically but just people
that cherry pick story we focus on this
yes so you know we hear about these rape
groups now
in england and that there were major
cover-ups we hear about these no-go
zones
uh we hear about plenty of the street
preachers and what's happening in the
mosques and all this stuff
i've tried incredibly hard for the years
that i've been doing this show
to separate the ideas of islam which is
a set of ideas that should be criticized
the same way you could criticize the
ideas that are judaism or the ideas of
christianity or the ideas that are
capitalism or anything else of course
versus muslims who are people the vast
majority who want the same exact things
that you want and i want and everybody
else
how big of an issue do you think this
this battle
between the ideas of islam and
the west is or did i even frame that
properly no i think it's fair the way
you frame it and i think it would be a
great thing
if we were able to in our daily lives
i'm talking about in the uk
if we were able to separate those two
things out nice and neatly so that
it was about islam and the ideology and
the criticism of that
versus regular muslims living in the uk
many of whom are working very hard many
of them have been here for generations
and just want to crack on and do the
same as the rest of us which is
look after our families worked hard and
try and be vaguely healthy and
and happy as much as we can but i think
the problem for us by the way we could
be a lot better about that argument
right here in america too so yeah that's
not unique to you guys because i try to
do it all the time
and still get thrown in with the people
that are not doing that yet no but i i
think
in the uk the problem with trying to
have that kind of educated approach and
that differentiation of those two
positions
is that when we live amongst it so much
and the attacks are so relentless
it's hard so as you're walking across if
i think now
you know if i'm walking across
westminster bridge to the house of
commons
you know the fact that there are these
concrete bollards up
that now separate people on pavements
from the roads
you know when we go to certain junctions
now there's concrete bollards so that
trucks can't drive into you
when you're crossing i think that we
live amongst that so much that there's a
fear of the
acid attacks where the police have just
been putting out what to do
in the instance of an acid attack and
what to do
so this is kind of the new one now yeah
so the new so for the evolution for us
so it was the terror attack
especially across ramadan in the summer
that sort of peak terror for us we had
the manchester bomb as well
then we had the police saying you know
you run you hide
you tell run hide tell that's the
message from the police
so that was pushed out and of course
that goes against everything inside of
me that says
no you chase them you fight them you try
your best you die trying
that feels more like the advice i want
to hear and there was a few people one
millwall football supporter who did
precisely that he fought
those attackers with their knives and he
got taken apart but he survived
but anyway run hide tell that feels
wrong that's not british to me
and now we've got the latest police
advice which is for acid attacks because
the latest is to come up on a moped
squirt sulfuric acid and take people out
that way and the acid attacks are sort
of you know whatever it says it's this
it's rinse it's repeat it's something uh
cover
and it's weird to me that we live in a
time where that's our police advice
is about how to cope with terror and
acid i find it really hard then to
differentiate right let's be a sensible
philosophical debate about islam versus
i need a concrete bollard to get over
that bridge and here's my advice for
terror
and i also think you know we had surveys
done 52
of muslims in the uk believe
homosexuality
should be illegal 52 of the muslims
you know and the the level of support
for terror attacks from muslims living
in the uk is very high and then for
example when the grooming gangs attack
you know we have that in so many of our
cities they are coordinated
they are networked they are devastating
and they see white girls my daughters
as trash we don't see many imams
ever standing outside the courts to just
say
not in the name of our religion and i
would have liked to see that more i'd
like to see
feminists also saying this is not right
but i don't hear that there seems to be
a silence on the left about all of that
so i think you've already answered this
but what do you think that odd alliance
i mean i've had a zillion guests on to
talk about this but this strange
alliance between feminine
feminism and islam i mean there is an
alliance between two things that should
by all accounts be completely at odds
with each other yeah so in
on the left for me it seems to me there
is a very clear
hierarchy of things you accept so you
accept on the left
first of all multiculturalism like that
is your bedrock that's the foundation of
everything that's the number one thing
you have to accept
and then things fall under that in a
hierarchy that we could argue about
so maybe lgbt maybe black probably black
lives matter goes above that
you could put the environment somewhere
this is a hierarchy
so when it comes to homophobia
in uh the islamic community the muslim
community
it's still multiculturalism still takes
precedent
and that's why you have the silence
there's a thought vortex
where they can't possibly stick up for
um
you know or reject or denounce the idea
that it's not acceptable to be
homophobic in the uk
because multiculturalism and respect for
the muslim faith
is higher on their hierarchy of thinking
it's a bit like maslow's hierarchy
right it's a new hierarchy of thought
but if it was christians
with those exact same beliefs you would
say that they're a bunch of homophobes
but for whatever reason
these their hierarchy christians comes
much lower and in fact just last night
um i don't know what time i crawled into
bed after political i think it was 3 30
in the morning don't tell my father
um i'm 42. um but uh
so i i was i had an email from someone
asking so people email me when they need
things to be heard or they feel so
frustrated
they know that i will can help give them
a voice so someone emailed me because
our police very much now pushing
reporting of hate crime
because uh they are driven to do that
through their
policing strategy is to push people
towards to reporting hate crime which of
course why you see hate crime go up
um and they are kind of rewarded on
achieving hate crime figures as part of
their reporting
anyway hate crime reporting is very big
in the uk police departments are pushing
it about the right
about the right wing not not really
about left or if you've had hate maybe
someone threatened to rape you with a
machete that doesn't matter
um but even if you go on uh to one of
the police
forces i don't want to misquote it i
think it might be bedfordshire i'd need
to double check
but when you go on and you try and log a
hate crime christianity
isn't even there so it asks you to say
your religion whether you're a buddhist
whether you're muslim whether you're
whatever
christianity is not even on the list and
i think that says something
huge about the way christianity is
perceived
in the uk is not even being relevant
enough to be a category on a drop down
menu
anymore yeah and what's odd is that
these things are now
truly becoming systemic because wasn't
there a story just about a month ago
that the bbc specifically was telling
white people not to apply to certain
jobs
yes so that's something i've reported
about for a while so creative access
the company is called uh we managed to
or i ran some things in the daily mail
eventually their funding was stopped for
a while but they are back
uh their funding source they have found
a new source of funding
like i say these these uh viruses tend
to
evolve to overcome i see myself as the
anti-bacteria antibiotic but they evolve
and they come back to creative access uh
creative it really is the only color so
it's available in any color as long as
it's not white
right um like all good vans and uh
i think um if you're black uh minority
ethnic
you can apply and one of the interesting
things as well it's always for positions
where no
qualifications are required either so
it's literally
a free job for you the only thing you
cannot be is white
and that is to most positions for the
bbc and it's linked intrinsically
through the establishment
so that they're getting more
representation of the sorts of faces
they want
what do you make of the intentions of
these people so i'm with you i hear you
obviously most of my audience hears you
get it they've been trying to fight this
leftism you know i told you beforehand
you know i mean i used to be a lefty and
now i realize that liberalism
in in the way that i view it has nothing
to do with being on the left but i try
not to impugn everyone's motivated on
the road to damascus
you had a sore like moment and you saw
the light yeah exactly so
uh although i don't know that i'd be
welcome in damascus but we'll see but
but point is that that i try not to
impugn everyone's motives
what do you think are the motives of
these people when they sit there in that
boardroom
at this company and they're doing all
this you think this is just misguided
craziness or
or are there people that truly are
trying to do what i'm not even sure
so there's two thoughts i have one i
don't like to imagine is true and the
other one
is that it is just the correct thought
the approved mind think in the uk in
terms of that hierarchy of thinking
the approved mind think is
multiculturalism the bbc achieves
funding if it takes its multiculturalism
and multicultural objectives and as we
look to see
how that maps out through the things
that we see we read we watch we see more
and more of the faces that we're
supposed to accept so that's my
that's my surface level interpretation
it's correct groupthink
um and it's a proved thing my more
sinister
uh interpretation that i don't like to
go near because it sends me down to the
tinfoil hat brigade and it makes me very
concerned
is that it's part of a wider approved
and soros-backed movement of people that
is
accept that the world is changing except
mass migration of the third world to the
first so this is when
when when alex jones talks about the the
globalist though right that's
that that version of this yes which and
i watch and i and i try and do
the thing you talked about so i do try
and discipline myself i always ask
myself what would someone else say what
would someone that hated me say what
would
my what would my husband say like my
husband is the opposite of me
he's known as lovely mark he wears soft
shoes he's got an earring
he votes labor i said i would leave the
country if labour got in he went
straight down to that polling station
and voted labour oh so i think to myself
what would mark say i
try out but my point is uh i think that
the thoughts of people that talk about
globalization the soros backed
takeover of the first world of europe i
believe that may be
the true interpretation of why this is
being forced through the establishment
and i see that in all different ways so
um
i have traveled to sweden and seen i've
been through no-go malmo through the
no-go zones and seeing women that are
too frightened to go out at night
because it's terrifying there
i just came back from libya and the med
watching
and plotting on their satellite tracking
data as well as standing at the ports
interviewing individuals
to watch the ngo ferries leave watch
them the tugboat come out
so the ngo ferry goes over the tugboat
comes out from the libyan shore
drops something in the water and goes
back and then the ngo boats all came
back two and a half thousand migrants
into sicily during the week that i was
there
i watch this i see these faces
coming to us through creative access
where only black people are acceptable
and then i also see that the mayors the
mayoral positions in the uk
which you can it's much easier to get a
mayor in that you specifically want to
get
the the way that the muslim mayors in
the uk are spreading
and the power is starting to spread we
have a muslim mayor as you know in
london
that's when i go down the tin four hat
route but i start to think
perhaps that is true perhaps it is
actually a much
bigger strategic globalist plan that is
about taking over
western europe yeah and you know i have
one of carl sagan's books over there
who's my favorite scientist of all time
and one of my favorite thinkers and he
would as i quote all the time
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence so a lot of the
stuff that you're talking about
i think about a lot of that stuff too i
have plenty of guests to think about it
and then you know the other part of me
wants that that evidence but perhaps
you just don't get it in life well i
think you can fight you find
not the big picture evidence but you can
find small pieces of the puzzle and in a
way that's what i've spent i suppose the
last 12 18 months doing
is just going to the jungle in calais
and watching the truckers you know under
tear gas watching
the migrants get on the backs of trucks
spending 48 hours in a truck
seeing truckers have their paths blocked
by trees being felled so the migrants
could get on the lorries
going to the med i'm just gesturing at
your world map
people wondering over there somewhere
over there your world map i've been to
the med
i don't know if it is over there but um
to watch the ngo ferry boats arriving
that are also funded through
you know ways we can track the funding
uh to see these pieces to go to sweden
where
the liberals want to tell you it's all
fine but actually you go to no go malmo
and i'm the only girl and i got told to
go suck your mum
you know because i was even daring to be
out after five o'clock at night
and you start to piece together these
bits of the jigsaw
and you start to see that maybe that
picture
does add up to something quite a bit
darker
than you might like to think it's almost
too sinister to go there
because you wonder then as i'm a mom
i've got three children they are 12 11
and 8
you do then wonder what does that mean
for the country that you believed in so
passionately you wanted to be in the
military to defend it
so it's inside me it's a burning anger
standing watching those boats ferrying
migrants ferrying men
knowing that they're worth 45 euros
ahead to the mafia that run them
it's an anger in me that we're watching
this happen and we've just seen mackerel
in france just buy up all the formula
one hotels that sounds quite jazzy
they're really rubbish hotels
i know they're called formula yeah but
they're not at all formula oh
yeah what's a really rubbish hotel chain
we probably can't say that yeah let me
not tell anybody out no so okay let's
imagine a hotel chain that you wouldn't
go to
the formula uh hotels i remember going
to them when i was doing french exchange
trips you know they put kids in them
yeah and macron has just bought them up
and he will now turn those hotels into
homes for the migrants and that's what
italy has done so i was at a
hotel for migrants in italy last week
and so another country goes like
it just the pattern is adding up the
picture is adding up
and it scares me all right so let's talk
a little bit more about multiculturalism
because i think multiculturalism has
worked pretty well
in america we are the melting pot
everyone comes here from
all over the earth they come here they
bring their traditions but you become
part of the greater tradition of america
this is something
that i'm very proud to live in this
country for and i think we've done it
like no other place in the history of
the world
is our experiment of multiculturalism
different and perhaps better than than
the way you guys have done it in europe
it's um so i love being in america i
love
that you will you people will chant usa
usa i love that i mean i appreciate that
that's politicon and other places where
i've seen it maybe on the trump trail
but i love that i love that people will
wear the american flag or or have
stuff that is kind of american flag
about them or they'll be proud of them
you are a window
right there what do you see you can't
get away from it you've got to be the
american flag well like you know you
i when i used to i do so when i lived in
new york i used to do run club every
sunday and before we ran
we sang the national anthem that that
kind of makes no sense to a british
person because it's like okay we'll just
sing the national anthem before we have
a little jog
that would never happen you do not hear
the national anthem at all in the uk
here it feels like the first thing
you should be or at least you are and if
you're not well you know whatever
is american and that has worked
brilliantly and i feel that you've got
it right and
i i'm urging at all times whenever i'm
speaking on fox or any of the stuff i do
is always to say look at
england look at the uk do not be us
do not become us that's always my plea
to america do not
look at us as the thing you don't want
to be
and when i look at the uk i know
that we don't have multiculturalism not
at all
we have ghettos of individual cultures
we have
monocultures living alongside each other
so you can even go to areas of london
and you'll know if you're in the
afghanistan area
the somalian area the eritrean area
or the pakistani area and the
interesting thing for me is when i went
to the jungle in calais where the
migrants live before they get on the
lorries if they can get on
is i went to an area i was looking for a
lady with her young
son who actually turned out to be a girl
but she dressed him as a boy so that
the daughter wouldn't get taken from her
or attacked by the men
that was upsetting enough but i went to
look for her in the afghani area
and they were like they were kind of
they were
shocked that i was she was somalian but
she wouldn't be here this is the
afghani area and that was in the migrant
camp of calais
now you take that and you bring that to
london the same
they come here they don't mix that's not
multicultural
and every old historic argument
conflict tension that they had in their
home
country they brought and they brought it
with them
and that's why you see the ban liu of of
paris is
you know those lines are delineated
where the hand grenades fall
and that's the same in sweden marked by
this culture all that
we don't have multiculturalism yeah so
so i'm glad you made that distinction
though because when you say you're
against multiculturalism you're actually
you're not really against
multiculturalism the idea of it you're
against the way it's been put into
practice put into practice and and the
the lie the disconnect the i think
mistruth
whatever where you want to package that
up so it sounds better
but the outright nonsense that britain
is a multicultural triumph
no you guys are i think italy actually
is still maintaining
there's something about being italian it
feels it's very strong it's all that
good food
it's great and when you're in southern
italy even though the migrant boats are
coming
being italian matters more and i really
enjoyed that when i was there
but we haven't got that right in the uk
we have not achieved
multiculturalism in its true sense we
have achieved a bunch
of mono cultures that still hate each
other and we're in amongst that
is anyone politically talking about this
in a way that you think is right like is
anyone
really addressing the heart of it no
we've lost where you've got like corbin
who's embracing it
right and then we've lost the uk has
lost its way at the moment so after
brexit
you know i was triumphant i was so
excited uh you know there's farage and i
kind of been
pushing bricks i was like the female
farage i guess i don't know what i was
uh horse faced old cow by the way
so yeah you know so so that was brexit
we had our tails up and then trump
got in life couldn't be better and then
now we've
lost all of that because we had the snap
election and and the people that voted
remain used
as their opportunity to have effectively
a second referendum
so we don't have anybody that's standing
up
for making britain great again we don't
have someone putting forward the ideas
that we need to reduce
the amount of state involvement in our
health care to overhaul our schooling
system so that only the brightest and
the best get through
to reduce the number of individuals
being educated to death for no reason
because they were barely literate before
they even got to university
we need to pull back the state and we
don't have anybody talking like that in
the uk
but we do have trump in america so i'm
yeah
well you've got you've got farage though
right but i guess but he's not part of
the government
no he's discredited he largely he's not
part of the government he's not
standing again he's not currently a part
of a party and you keep her falling away
because after brexit they didn't have a
place because the conservatives really
took their ground so
it's a it's a very disappointing place
in terms of when people talk about
you know i listen to the liberal comics
at politicon saying about how these are
dark times in america's dark times
you're a dark time what you're wearing
honey that is dark
but you go to the uk for someone like
who's a brexiteer without anybody to
look to for hope
and you go this is dark times we may not
get brexit we don't have anybody who
wants to make britain great again
and we don't have a voice that's going
to represent us just yet
what do you make of some of the
movements on the right in the uk and
that are happening throughout europe you
know like the edl and pagita
and all that stuff i think the the issue
with as soon as the label
many labels are ineffective now racist i
think is ineffective islamophobe is
ineffective because
enough of us can see that we're being
done harmed by a religion that we should
work out how to work alongside but i
think
in terms of being far right that label
still
has meaning and it's sufficient as a
label to discredit anything that
therefore is said
by that individual so as soon as you can
chuck a far
right label on it that's an excuse not
to even listen
not even here and even if that
individual let's take tommy robinson
uh is outside a court protesting against
muslim grooming gangs
rape squads rather if we're using true
terms
he'll be discredited and ridiculed and
just pushed away because he's far right
and of course that doesn't fit in the
hierarchy of
correct thought which then i think just
actually breeds support for tommy
robinson because if you watch i've had
him on the show
i i you know i've had majid on a couple
times yeah yeah major was talking about
him just a couple weeks ago right here
and they obviously have major issues you
know and tommy showed up at the offices
it's caused
all sorts of problems but for the most
part i think tommy does again make a
distinction between
ideas and people he has gone out he's
left organizations that were truly
racist
and then when people see the way he's
dismissed they go wait a minute he's not
really he's talking about
some [ __ ] that we need to talk about and
look at the way he's treated and then
they they
quietly are then supporting him i'd
rather have all this stuff out in the
open and
have everybody having this debate i
agree with you entirely he has a massive
support base and he is able to get his
support
base but that support praise does not
have reach
so it's it's a large number it's a big
volume of people but they're very
concentrated around
each other so their own little echo
chamber it doesn't have reach into the
establishment
or to the news media or to any of the
mainstream because they've managed to
pass it over to the far right
and they've also managed so when we had
the attack on a mosque
well there was a guy that drove into
some individuals outside the east london
mosque well known for not necessarily
being the most tolerant of places
uh just to be clear that that was the
mosque that the westminster
attackers came from right correct yes i
believe that's correct i believe that's
correct but i do know that i think it
was
amazing i'm not sure whether the
westminster attacker came from there
there was a history of that mosque
having issues in terms of its
okay the extremism that it was alleged
to have bred
but my point is as soon as that attack
happened which was just one guy in a van
that kind of went a bit crazy
that became that's tommy robinson that's
to blame
and the news agenda went straight to
tommy i saw that that night on twitter
yeah which is very silencing actually
because then even for his supporters
you don't be affiliated with someone
that's being said as being responsible
for that clearly he had no
responsibility for that but that's what
the media have created they have
portrayed him in a dark place and
actually that is where you end up over
on the far
hard right right so apparently ideas and
words do matter but only depending on
which way they come from yeah exactly
right
really bizarre exactly right and i think
so many i wouldn't want to ever try and
say i speak for britain
but certainly people that do maybe
support what i say
i think our frustration is that we see
so much hate enacted
on our own girls our children people
going to a concert people going out for
dinner
you know a 12-inch hunting knife pushed
through the face of a woman
eating you know on london bridge we're
not we're not supposed to talk
about that or suggest that that's linked
to religion and we're certainly not
supposed to report that and if we do
we're told that
maybe we're being racist whereas the
encouragement the
support to report any kind of hate crime
done by somebody maybe like myself
something i've said a tweet is very
there's a lot of funding
behind that kind of reporting so i'm
glad you mentioned that because one of
the things that i've seen on twitter
which i think is truly one of
the most outrageous ludicrous insane
things that i've seen on twitter
has been a few times where which is the
or which is the local police
that have oh yeah so london has met
police the metropolitan police come for
me so i'm not in there
so you've tweeted things whatever it is
that you've tweeted and then they've
requested that people report
you and refined other things that you've
said and all this stuff for hate speech
or whatever terms that they're using
even though as you've said i've done no
violence i'm not calling for violence
and they're literally word police now
yes so the word police are strong
um and just if i give maybe two or three
examples so that
so i i suppose this sort of woman thing
mom mom of three kids married
regular house quite like gardening
secret gardener on the side
so there's just me and maybe my network
of other fairly rubbish moms who aren't
that good at it and fairly crap
gardeners
that's how i see myself with my network
right yeah so then i write a column in a
national newspaper
one of the papers i used to work for and
that column became
the focus of the head of the unhr
um and he said that i was one of the
causes of all of the issues against
multiculturalism in the uk
i was brought in under caution by the
major crime and homicide command
interviewed by two people on a tape
and then that was taken to the cps the
crown prosecution service
to see if i would go up to be put given
jail time for a column in a national
paper
i have been reported to social services
for my children because people say my
twitter feed is so fierce i must be
hurting my children so social services
come just to check because they're
obliged to and i respect that
i've also been threatened i was called
when i was in australia i was going to
be repatriated
to the uk because of a tweet where i
called a nurse who'd come back
with ebola i called her a ebola bomb
and so i was going to be repatriated to
the uk for that and i've had two further
incidents of police
in my home telling me i need to play at
the police station for tweets so i am
heavily policed and uh my liberty i
suppose is under threat for the words
that i type
who is policing the police i mean so
when i see that or i see tommy i'll do
these periscopes where he'll be kicked
out of a bar and and he'll get the
camera right in the in the policeman's
face and he'll say oh i didn't do
anything i was just at a bar and someone
hit me over the head was saying or
someone's screaming at me
and they'll be like no no no you're just
by being here you're you're upsetting
people
or whatever it is the guy didn't break
any law as far as i can tell by anything
that you just said you didn't break
anything
i've seen similar things i think with
ann marie waters i mean just the
collection of people regardless of what
you think of them
that the law is being turned against
them for nothing
illegal i mean is anyone policing the
police is this an issue that anyone's
picking up
are there any liberals talking about
this no but i think there is a growing
movement i can feel it through my emails
through the people that get in touch
with me through some of the stuff that i
do i even have people from inside the
bbc
and inside the guardian newspaper which
is the big left-wing establishment
newspaper
i have some people inside there that
email me now to tell me things because
they respect what i'm trying to do which
is maybe just have other views heard or
just illuminate some things that we have
going on
but um i see that the way the police
operate and in a way the way we fight
back or the way that we police the
police i think
is by me using my platform to show what
they're doing so bedfordshire police
have just invested a massive sum of
sum of money trying to get people to
report twitter
feeds of people like me basically if
you're from the right
it's saying don't cross the line like
when will this person who's actually a
trump supporter
cross the line so they use that so
bedfordshire police who've spent all
this money on this are actually rated
the worst police force in the country
they are
they were reported as being unable to
function as a police source so i then
tweet that
so they see that the amount they're
vesting on trying to police me and my
twitter feed
versus the fact that they are the one of
the worst performing
police stations in the country and i
think by adding you're giving publicity
to showing them to say listen why don't
you focus on
your issues i think the same i had
um after a lot of the incidents and the
violence in manchester with the bombing
i had some people from inside the police
force email me to say that
actually the imams at the local mosque
decide who the two police officers are
that they will approve to go and patrol
their area
and the imams are in control of the
police officers i mean how does that
even
yes so then i take that email with the
permission of the sender make it
anonymous and post that
up and there were some things that came
off the back of that so i see my job now
as
helping to expose why we have so many
systemic level problems
about the way our country is going and
those sorts of things when i'm told that
the imams are selecting the police
officers who are muslim police officers
to be allowed to go near their areas
that's when i go into this but you know
the thing we talked about with the
pictures
the different pieces of the puzzle that
make a picture once you find out your
imams are picking your police
for you that can police them it mosques
you start to go down that route of
wondering
precisely what's going on yeah you know
i'm picturing one of my favorite movies
be for vendetta which did take place in
britain you know there's that moment
when the when the police officer is
putting it all together and he just
tells a story
and he says to his his you know sidekick
basically he's like this is going to
sound crazy
but here's my theory and that's how i
feel like i almost i
see the world i guess a little bit in
pictures anyway or i visualize things
but that's how i feel i feel like i take
my little piece of
of that's me at the camp at calais here
i am uh in libya and in the med
here i am in sweden in no-go zones here
i am with the guy telling me that the
imams picked the
the police that were allowed to police
here i am in the schools with the
children with their clinton mints and
all of a sudden this thing starts to
take
the shape of something that i'm almost
too scared of and i don't know i can't
stop now i have to keep going i think
but it's interesting the number of
things where they're trying to take me
down with police
or with social services of my children
or however which way they come
for me yeah i sense though that they
can't scare you
i i sense no wavering in you i mean it's
pretty clear i
i i feel utterly fearless and i don't
mean that in a weird sort of
like the feminist yesterday like oh my
god my [ __ ] is made of steel
that is not i was about to do this to
put on a [ __ ]
i have no [ __ ] hat and uh i'm proud of
that but
i i am definitely fearless because i
know ultimately the things that matter
to me are my family
my children my husband don't tell him i
said thanks
and then being healthy my husband
matters
um i am alpha female all the way um and
then being a healthy ish
as we can be and happy that's all that
matters so that's it
now outside of that are the things i
care about which is my country and i
will carry on
you telling me truth you emailing me
about what's gone on your police station
or inside the guardian or inside the bbc
or you're
misrepresenting white people i will talk
about that
and you can't take anything away from me
you may take away
my job at the newspaper you may have
just managed to get me kicked off my
radio show
it doesn't matter there will be another
platform if enough people feel that i
give them a voice
and that's why i applaud what you do and
what you guys are doing because you are
self-funded
you're the people that want to hear you
are paying for you
and i love this idea that that will be
the new
truth is that people will pay to be able
to hear the truths
that commissioners and tv commissioners
and people that work in the media
industry have tried to silence
and this is the new evolution of the us
and i think i will be
doing a similar thing hopefully coming
soon in the uk
where perhaps the people that feel
they're being silenced can help
fund a space where we will continue to
speak and we will evolve
over the viruses and we are the new
antibiotic that will say no we're going
to keep being heard and that feels
powerful and makes me
feel more fearless that was a nice
ending to this interview but i'm not
done with you yet oh
i'm not done but that was that felt like
the natural ending
but you know what i to to go off what
you just said there i think the most
beautiful thing that i didn't realize
until for about a year when i went
independent was that
i get those same emails from you from
all of us i get from christian
conservatives and i get
from progressives and i get from far
lefties and i get from
libertarians or whatever from all over
the place all over the world atheists in
saudi arabia
this whole freaking thing and it's like
the all these people support
what i'm doing and it's like i all i can
do is do what i think is right
when you have that kind of plurality of
support i can't
if i was i've said this all many times
but if i was to try to sell out tomorrow
i genuinely wouldn't know which way to
sell no truly i mean that is really the
truth
so all i can do is what i think is right
yes and i i feel that and i feel that
they're for the people that are funding
what you're doing they're not funding
you to say a certain thing it's not that
weird kind of fun to donate thing
they're funding you just to have the
platform and if they don't like what
you've said they're also going to tell
you that
or they don't start funding me they'll
also have the opportunity to stop
funding but
maybe you'll pick up another funder over
there but what i love the idea is that
these
this bastion this institution the
establishment that maybe
could be linked to the soros kind of
program of mass movement people or may
not be
let's not go there but the idea that you
will now move over the top of them
and have your own platform that they
cannot filter through you cannot have a
commissioner who's a lefty that says no
we don't need her talking
you've gone beyond that i think he's
incredibly powerful and i also think
those people
need you and that's why you can't stop
it becomes almost like a religion of
itself i know
i know yeah but as i told you before we
started as of this interview
i'm taking basically make a shot of god
until september 5th hopefully the world
doesn't
miss it though now but then i kept
thinking if the world ends literally if
it ends while i'm gone am i going to
have to jump back on twitter just for a
second just to say goodbye or no
just let me just do the best thing you
can do if the world is about to end
never be back on twitter don't even do
don't even do the ribbon report as much
as i love it
you know let's all get a sense of
ourselves let's get over here let's look
in the sunset and let's
remember the beautiful things that
happened in your life open up that one
great bottle of wine
sounded like a right feminist right
there didn't i you really did
um let's talk for a second about any
frustrations that you might have with
your team
do you think the right or do you think
the trump people
or the conservatives or whatever you
want to call all that
are they doing anything wrong here do
you see any flaws in your side is
anything up that we should know about of
course the right do
so many things wrong and i would never
in any way think that my loyalty it goes
beyond anything they do wrong that i
wouldn't call them out on it
i think one thing we don't do enough of
is just being
very true about what we're celebrating
and what we're actually celebrating what
we're actually all about in my personal
opinion
is freedom we're all about liberty
we are the true i think libertarians we
are the people that want small state
want you to
choose what you do be what you want to
be live how you want to live do it don't
do it
that's what i think we're all about and
i don't think we get that message across
clearly at all conservatives always come
across as the
the former ones the sensible ones the
ones that are about war the ones that
want to put more people in police
stations the ones that want to lock
people up in jail
i don't think that's the truth of us
we've given ourselves this weird
kind of outfit this uniform of being
terribly strict and terribly proper
actually we're the dirtiest hookers on
the block because we say
live your life and we need to get more
of that message across but we just want
you to live it well
live it within the rules of law and
order we want you to pay your taxes be
happy
and have your family and be proud of
them and that's the more positive
conservative message that i want to help
spread
that's what i think we need to do to
make britain great again as well and i
think we need much less state in our
life because wherever the state
interferes
we typically fail and our national
health service if i could make another
plea to america
would be please look carefully beyond
the headlines at the uk national health
service
because it is falling on its ass because
it is the worst of all solutions
do not look to western europe as i heard
said last night like some
great kind of golden goose in the sky of
what you want to become you don't want
that
yeah you want private health insurance
health
is not a right i think health is a good
and the more we see it that way the more
we drive the free market to create the
solution for us
uh the better we are all right well i
think that was two good closing
statements but i'll give you an update
i'll give you an opportunity for one
more
so just surmising all this and then i
think you're gonna stick around for a
quick rapid fire thing that we're doing
for our patrons only
um what's next for you
is it just is it just continuing this
adventure um
so i think uh i wouldn't like to say
that i'm massively strategic in my
operations but i also have a kind of
cunning plan behind
in so inside is this engine of
determination that i will not
be taken down that i will stand strong
and that that is very clear you're not
hiding that part
that's the engine that drives it i think
they're the way the road i'm going down
so there is a book that will come out
in september that casey hopkins rude and
i guess it is
quite rude um which is like kind of the
making of me and why i'm the way i am
my father would say is incredibly
problematic um
i'm going to be uh doing a new program
which will be about linking funding
to ensuring people have their voices
heard that's coming out the back end of
this year which will be into 2018 and we
will bypass the establishment
we will bypass the commissioners and we
will bypass all the left-wing that seem
to want to narrate
how england is which i'm not having any
more of
and then into next year i think doing
more of the same but trying to stand for
something trying to build some kind of
way of taking
a new conservative force forward that is
about
living life positively about a small
state and about
you know bringing britain back to what
we thought was great
in a really positive way we do embrace
multiculturalism but we do it well
where we do have schools that function
and allow people to leave when frankly
they don't need educating anymore
and where we do say that you are going
to take responsibility and
accountability yourself
but we'll support you in it that's kind
of my path
and i'm kind of excited at all times
about it so it's good but i would say
to anybody my detractors that created me
is that we will keep evolving we will
keep being better and we will keep being
heard and you will not silence us
that's three endings now well i just
want how many more does a man need
that's it i will not ask you for any
more but
it was a pleasure talking to you and i
think more than anything more than
anything else because
of the fact that i see what people say
about you and all those things and i've
had this a few times on the show where i
have invite guests on that people say
horrible things and then you sit across
from somebody for an hour
and unless you're a regular dude unless
you're the charlatan of all time i
i see a pretty decent person they're
trying to be so good so thank you
that's kind it was a pleasure talking to
you and for more on katie
follow her on the twitter for all her
adventures and for the police the uh
which one is it again
oh for before police and what they're up
to they're constantly watching her
it's at kt hopkins
[Music]
you